eric jones jr acquired from miami as a
free agent
hounding curry on the relocate and steph
with the deep two
and so they get an improved defense to
go with this brilliant offense
they're gonna make noise in the west
curry around covington pass nurkic lay
it up and in
who's on him you switch covington on to
him look at the moves
counter back the other way through the
legs nurkish gets there too late
mccollum picked up his second foul so
gary trent jr is checked in
warriors stay with the same five
starters and steph
curry hitting the wing jumper yeah drop
it in that three
oh curry little split smart step through
and step with the lamp and so steph
curry beautiful beginning
and the turnover four-point trip down
as they have the technical free throw in
the three-point play curry right down
the lane
how about that that is how you expose
canter high
high pick and roll looking for steph
good screen by base more three on the
way
perfect set the screen move the ball
and get that kid the ball that's great
defense though
and then steph off of made three
reversing it up and in oh
curry what a first quarter getting
downhill you see cantor there he's like
great news cantor's on me let me get
around him super easy
crafty finishes and his reaction to the
foul that just happened oh
they're sending him to the right wiseman
slipping
and hammering past the derrick wiser
watch
watch him just push him straight into
wiseman and wiseman just releases to the
best that's one of the better sequences
of the year
wiseman saved the turnover steph cut
back door little floater
steph curry's got 23. teardrop me
steph he reloaded went around
mccollum and made that turn warriors
nine point lead in the ball three and a
half remaining in the first half
curry hiding behind looney weaving
through traffic down the lane lefty
finish
steph is doing everything there is a
different energy to this man's game
draymond three sure it's a pass to the
step
it's a pass we'll call it to pass great
look
the field goal the five that's a good
draw and kick
and steph just had position derek jones
jr was behind him and just stayed behind
him
and look at the pass look i see
especially when he's that wide open well
he started the season one of 13. he's
only 22
on the year curry for three lasers at
home
steph has the new building high of 40.
they obviously have not played with big
leads all year
curry little floater he's got 42.
that teardrop is just so frustrating for
biggs seconds game shot clock
to wind down this third step
step back three yeah 45
for curry oh my goodness the dribble
combinations it's the best way to get a
clean look with double teams having all
that stuff
sometimes it's 35 feet out ricochet to
steph he just catches and launches a
three
like that he's got 48. this is the three
from steph it was to draymond he
couldn't get to it but it was a perfect
pass to steph
harry tran jr staying on top of steph
working with wiseman
little leaner push shot he's got 50.
and this is just steph taking his time
you see gary trent jr right behind him i
mean lillard and mccollum went for 54
but steph went for 56 by himself
curry from deep 59. why not
man steph just steph is running into the
front court
draymond finds him another three got it
62 62
and he actually surpasses his buddy clay
thompson they're looking forward to
draymond green of course his boy
where's he at where's the at handoff
that is a tough shot too gary trent
right at him